let's talk to their CEO Michael O'Leary
good morning to you have been clearly
very grim news what what is it about
your forecasts here that that makes you
think that this sort of action is
necessary a good morning to see you and
to all your viewers like you know we've
never faced a period like this in the
airline industry we will have this
morning where you said will carry about
on less than 150,000 passengers in the
three months to June compared to a
budget of 42 Millions
there were 99.5 percent behind our
original traffic projections we do
expect to be back flying but a limited
program into by July August into
September but for the current year now
we're going to carry less than that
there are less than two-thirds less than
a hundred million of our original budget
of 150 million passengers so we'd be
carrying about one-third fewer
passengers in the next 12 months when we
do return to flying it's now clear we're
going to have to fly with both hands
tied behind our back because our
competitors of fans ax I've just
received 12 billion in state aid Air
France is going to receive 10 billion
and stay hey these guys will have the
money to engage in below cost selling
for the next three or four years so not
only facing less flying with fewer
flights but prices are going to be
incredibly low which is good for
consumers but bad for the airlines and
if we're going to carry a third less
prancer's this year I'm afraid we're
going to need fewer pilots and fewer
chemicals and this morning we've
announced the plan starting a process of
consultation with the unions we're going
to have to lose about 3,000 pilots and
camera crew that's about 15% of our
workforce and the remainder will be
facing pay cuts for the next 12 years
through our 12 months 22 years of about
up to 20% obviously I mean a key part of
your concern here is apart from the
people that you're losing and I'm sure
you've got a lot of concern for them but
but this this 30 billion euro in in
state aid now you're you're claiming
that that that is it illegal if it is
illegal under II into under EU rules
how on earth of these countries getting
away with it because the French and the
Germans were
do something just ignore the rules
themselves anyway I mean if you look at
most of the airlines including Ryanair
we're on payroll and support schemes at
the moment across Europe that's
sufficient for us for the weather on
airlines like ba
easyJet and others to get through the
next couple of months until we come back
flying but your fans and their France
not lunar receiving at state payroll
supports they're now getting this
financial doping of state aid the French
government for example in the last month
have announced a rule where they're
going to refund airport taxes but only
for French airlines the non French
airlines that Ryanair easyJet and pa who
do fly to France will have to keep
paying these Airport taxes it's
manifestly unfair it's in breach of the
state hate rules and it's in breach of
competition rules but it would take us
12 18 months you know to go to court to
overturn these decisions an Italian the
meantime has been nationalized and in
that 12 month or 18 month period we're
going to face torrid trading conditions
yes I think we will return strongly
faster numbers would be strong but this
could be 50 million down in the next 12
months for Ryanair but fares will be
much lower than we had originally
budgeted for you know we expect in the
first quarter of this year which is our
information period we're going to lose
about 100 million euros we've never lost
money in that first quarter in our
history in Ryanair and if it shows just
how difficult it is so we regret these
job cuts we regret these pay cuts but
they're what the well-run airlines like
Ryanair others will have to do just to
survive and compete against and the
likes of Lufthansa and Air France
receiving tens of billions of state aid
from their national governments can I
just ask you almost as an aside here
because there are other things I want to
chat about it but but when you talk
about your staff taking pay cuts some of
them are going to want to know if you're
taking a pay cut yeah my papers cooked
for a while we started off originally I
cut my pay by 50% for April and May and
we've now extended that pay cut up a cod
fish because I think I'll run all the
way through to next March of 2021 and
further until we emerge over this code
with 19 pandemic okay
look can I ask can I ask about the the
social distancing in aeroplanes
situation which has arisen easyJet has
said it will be prepared to fly with the
the middle seats empty you said earlier
this week or last week that Ryanair
would not do that I mean it's you know
obviously would hit margins
substantially but under the
circumstances might your view on that
change in that if you're making any sort
of profit on a flight it might be worth
doing at this time no see very well
firstly remember taking out the business
seat in an aircraft that she's no social
distancing you're less than two feet
away that's the two feet between the
iron and the window seat there's even
less pay than two feet between the seat
behind you on the eye and the seat in
front of you on the social distancing on
an airline or an airline an aluminium
tube cynthia is impossible and what we
are recommending and I think what the
industry is moving towards is passengers
and cabins were wearing face masks at
all time onboard temperature checks on
passengers at the airport so that
anybody who has a temperature about 38
degrees will simply be asked to go home
and self isolate and that's what the
Asian airlines are doing and doing quite
successfully and it's helping to spread
are helping to limit any risk of spread
of kovat 19 on one our short flights
mean brilliant both on board around
aircraft for typically one hour 50
minutes but middle seat empty is
nonsense on smaller aircraft you don't
even have means of seats what you do on
those aircraft that have only two seats
oppressed so social distancing on board
and aircraft on the London Underground
on trains simply isn't possible and but
we do and we recognize the need for some
sensible precautions but we believe a
combination of temperature shapes at
airports and train stations at the
London Underground and face masks being
more about everybody while on board the
Underground trains aircraft particularly
on shore flight is a sensible and much
more worrying effective measure to spray
our to excel to limit the spread of
Corbin 19 Michael O'Leary appreciate
your time this world